foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's keynote
presentation titled a generic
manufacturing platform for Downstream
processing on nomob proteins this
webinar is part of the fourth annual bio
processing virtual event and I'm Susie
Valdez of Labyrinth and I will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labroots so let's get started before we
begin I want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our live chat feature during the
presentation you can find this live chat
located at the right of your screen you
can also participate by submitting as
many questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation now if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation just
simply click on the help desk button
located at the bottom of your screen
within the navigation bar or from the
lobby and finally as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits link
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits without
further Ado I now present today's
speaker out Dr Ella with younger a
professor in the department of
biotechnology at the University of
natural resources and Life Sciences at
The Institute of bioprocess Science and
Engineering in Vienna Austria for a
complete biography of our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the left of
your screen Dr youngbauer welcome you
mean now begin your presentation sir
thank you for the introduction I think
everybody can see my slides I guess so
uh good uh morning uh those who are
actually in U.S and good evening uh to
the attendees uh here in Europe I have
seen even we have attendees from Austria
yeah so it will be a pleasure to give
you an overview on the production and
purification mainly the downstream
processing of non-mob proteins yeah we
all know that 60 percent of uh
biopharmaceutical proteins are
antibodies yeah but still there are a a
big fraction of proteins which are
therapeutic proteins which are not
antibodies and they also have to be
purified the advantage of the antibodies
is the generic Downstream processing
platform with protein a
and I think I don't want to actually
spend a lot of time on this protein a
generic platform because it is so well
known yeah and it's so common and well
accepted in industry
so we have worked in the past on
actually a generic manufacturing
platform
and while all generic manufacturing
platforms and then we came also across
other uh uh platforms I drive to give
you uh an overview of couple of these
platforms how they can uh be used for
the production of non-map proteins yeah
discuss the pros and cons and then I
will give you also a couple of examples
from our latest development
so uh the new Terror knocked down a new
data poetic concept but a lot of
therapeutic concepts are based on either
enzymes antibody fragments peptides
cytokines hormones and also a
protein-based vaccines yeah
they what they have in common in respect
to bioprocess engineering is they suffer
from a low development ability and
manufacturability yeah
and they they need there is a need for a
generic manufacturing and downstream
processing this is clear yeah uh
compared to antibodies we cannot
actually uh uh be sure once we have
overexpressed an antibody IGG that we
can capture purify the antibody with
protein a Affinity chromatography so
that's that's not possible yeah so we
actually have to uh find other ways
so I think the concept of fusion protein
technology is actually not new this has
been pretty old
uh um maybe some of you have heard the
name Matthias Elaine yeah he already
started in the 60s mid of the 60s so
a couple of decades ago yeah to
overexpress proteins with the protein a
a deck and then beautified through an
immunoglobal in G uh uh Affinity
chromatography so this was the early
start yeah so and others tried to take
protein so that you have a purification
attack when you see on the left upper
left on my slide yeah you have a
purification deck a link and then the
target protein or some sometimes it is
called the protein of Interest the POI
the POA
you could express them uh are they
purify them with sexually uh an affinity
chromatography which is specifically
recognizing the tag and afterwards you
have to leave off the deck once you
leave off the deck uh actually a small
peptide remains on the end terminals of
the target protein or the protein of
interest if you have the tag on the C
terminals the same would happen uh
actually that you have an elongated
actually protein on the C terminus
there was a big debate there is still a
big debate if we need an authentic and
Terminus so if we have to generate a
protein which actually is cleaved really
at the end Terminus yeah
um several uh groups over the past
years let's say decades have tried to
actually uh generate a a generic
expression system which relies on what
you see on the right hand side of this
slide where the the
protein is also packed with a Linker but
then uh uh uh the the Linker with the
deck is cliffed off in a way that an
authentic and terminals is generated
so now let's go a little bit so this is
very generic this is a very generic
procedure uh it is very well established
uh uh in on laboratory scale but
actually really used in a large-scale
Manufacturing
and one thing is and this is the crucial
point this was always this cleavage of
uh the tag and the link yeah so
let's do the next so the the image what
we could do is an enzymatic cleavage
we could do a Decay so it's kind and a
quote-unquote an auto protease
the oldest way is the chemical cleavage
and then the Indians and the Indians is
also a kind of a chemical uh cleavage
yeah so it's not really yeah so
that's the chemical image uh were the
first method really to uh uh actually
Cliff Fusion takes uh uh from the
protein of Interest yeah this is China
10 bromide uh um actually eclipse at the
meteor9 so this is really uh uh but then
you have a lot of side reactions that
this has been done in the past uh and uh
in this insulin processes chemical
cleavage have been used quite a lot yeah
but due to this uh uh actually a lot of
side reactions and you see you use a
very hazardous chemical this really has
not been become very popular huh
so
uh there is one here what you see if you
do like a fusion protein a cleavage you
could what I showed here already
at the first you have this conventional
tag link Target protein then you would
have tag intain Target protein a bond
actually changing uh the redox potential
the dag would be cleaved off uh through
the 18 yes because the indane decays
yeah so that's uh or or is disrupted
yeah
the other thing is the auto protease so
this is also a kind of 50K
a lot of uh
viral proteins are generated or
expressed
as a long uh polypeptide yeah and at the
end Terminus there is an auto protease
which actually chops up the viral
protein in into this different let's say
proteins yeah and this uh biological
phenomenon can be used to generate
actually a system for Fusion Tech
cleavage so this Auto protease is
overexpressed quite often in form of an
of inclusion bodies non-native yeah and
upon redaturation yeah uh there is a
specific cleavage of uh the the auto
protease from the target protein
so you see we have used the auto Proteus
and bro uh uh a couple of years ago and
this is uh uh from the classic swine
fever virus here
and you see this function in nature is
proteolytic cleavage yeah of the viral
uh uh uh uh propoli protein so these are
non-structured proteins yeah
uh it is uh rather big yeah uh and we
made a mutant of this uh uh and bro yeah
and it's quite interesting uh what you
see here uh for this uh kind of Decay
when you do this in profusion uh you see
on the left hand side the end bro so in
in red with the target
uh overly expressed as inclusion bodies
and then uh uh upon refolding the embryo
is cliffed off and a Target protein with
uh the authentic n-terminals is
liberated on the right hand side of my
slide yeah you see the markers the
inclusion bodies and the Regeneration
and rather than seed and in Gray where
they were our Target protein in green is
uh our uh a clear Fusion day so this is
quite fascinating the
advantage of such a system is that what
you see here already that it is
overexpressed is quite a lot of
protein yeah and the inclusion bodies
can be washed and are already pretty
pure yeah
so uh the disadvantages that you have to
refold yeah and a lot of
scientists don't like these three
folding also industry does not like to
revote only uh uh a couple of uh
companies uh really let's say uh felt in
love with uh
refolding of proteins yeah uh so then uh
you see uh another another there are
another examples here uh what you could
do and the interesting thing is when you
see here on the left hand slide so there
will be the marker uh then you have to
induce the non-induced the inclusion
bodies the renature re-naturated and
then on this first
SAS page you see the line B and this is
precipitated and this is quite
interesting because there are end bro uh
is not soluble at acidic pH yeah so you
lower the ph you like pH four or so four
yeah then the uh uh Ed bro is uh is
precipitating and the target protein is
intercupulated so this is a pretty
simple straightforward process yeah so
you see it also uh as uh uh two more
examples yeah uh on the the second and
the third uh slide where uh actually we
see we speed 1 B2 uh where we were able
really to precipitate actually the
diffusion tag and uh have a a rather
fewer you see without any further
chromatography a rather pure uh uh
attack
antex protein with an authentic and
terminals yeah
so
then
um
here you see some of these refolding
strategies yeah uh and production
strategies is the culture Bros the
centrifocation the homogenization the
centrifugation then we would have the
the dissolution of the inclusion bodies
uh into either
urea or guanidine hydrochloride industry
uh
likes uh quantity uh relaxuria sorry
luxuria yeah and then on the left hand
side you would go for the refolding and
then the outer precipitation and then
you have a centrifugation what I have
showed you while you go to a refolding
reactor and then do like a conventional
purification by a chromatography
so now uh let's go for the enzymatic
cleavage yeah
and before
um I I
explained you about the etymatic
cleavage let me talk a little bit about
the properties or the specificity of
enzymes we have a protease yeah uh and
the substrate yeah so the the the
substrate actually uh uh the protease
recognizes a certain uh amino acids so
this is the specificity yeah uh on the
left hand side the amino acids up the
cleavage uh it's called B1 B2 B3 B4 yeah
but there's this substrate and on the
right hand side is P1 Prime P2 Prime and
so on yeah so that's uh actually when
you now wanna actually generate a
protein with authentic and Terminus yeah
your protein proteinase has to cleave
off uh between the B1 and the B1 Prime
side yeah otherwise you would not be
able actually to generate an authentic
interminus
but a lot of uh proteases are not
specific enough
so
uh let me review now a couple of them
yeah so which are commercially available
and used a lot in in the lab so you have
the oxy proteinase yeah the axi uh
protein is preferentially uh glyphs at
Arginine in position P1 yeah so if you
have another if you have another amino
acid in in B1 yeah you cannot use this
oxy proteinase
uh uh and uh if there is an another uh
uh amino acid uh uh actually uh uh that
you is not useful and also the P1 Prime
will interact uh and and will moderate
uh uh this cleavage
but then there is a lot of there are a
lot of car spaces have been used so
caspase seven cut Space Nine caspase ten
so these are uh enzymes uh uh which are
uh are
are overexpressed or induced
upon apoptosis yeah they are a little
bit more uh uh
more uh
useful for Cleavage of uh
Fusion proteins yeah but you see here
the caspase-7 has a four amino acid
recognition sites and the P1 Prime side
that is relatively uh flexible also the
seven and the 10 yeah
so but the problem of this car space is
they are very difficult to produce
and uh you cannot over Express you have
to over Express them in E coli in a
prokaryotic system because the car space
is actually
are
induced upon cell tests yeah so they
cannot be produced in eukaryotic uh
uh production strains
a very common uh enzyme is the tobacco H
virus protease the death protease
recognizes a linear epitope uh which uh
actually uh can accept quite a lot of
substrates yeah and uh cleavage occur
between glutamine and glycine or
glutamine and serine yeah
uh uh and it is very common used in
small scale but uh not in industrial or
preparative scale because the enzyme is
terribly uh expensive yeah so
then we have the enterokinase is quite
interesting so recognizes a certain
amino acid sequence what you see here uh
with a relatively High uh specificity
so here you know you got an inside by
reviewing these different proteases
there are a lot more yeah so I could
talk an hour just on this proteases
which has been have been used for the uh
uh actually cleavage of fusion proteins
but you get an A A an Insight how
delicate it is and how difficult it is
uh uh to generate and appropriate fusion
protein system for large-scale
manufacturing yeah so this is the reason
why this technology also it is
platformer have not really entered a
industry
but it still remained with uh uh with
Academia so uh here you see only a
couple of fusion tags this could be uh
peptides or proteins like the history
the seed eggs a biopty mimetic
polyhistics B5 State mixtape and so on
uh hemoglobin intake yeah and then
protein proteins like uh the
the the carotene binding protein mitos
binding protein
glutathione as transferase so uh
for a technical purpose yeah uh you
wanna use a small attack think about you
have a big tank yeah if you have a big
tank
you sacrifice a lot of your metabolism
of the cell to produce the take
and not uh the protein of Interest so
over the metabolic uh a lot of metabolic
activity of the cells go into the
production of tech and not uh the
protein of Interest so this would be a
based
of uh of uh metabolic activities
therefore we want to have our Fusion tag
as small as possible yeah so as small as
possible you could use or large eggs
have used for other purposes
Ida for uh increasing the solubility
for detection or fish proteins have been
used a lot yeah uh for increasing the
half-life of a protein these are for
instance the FC fusions yeah to increase
the half-life of a small protein yeah
but this is not actually the subject of
this talk here
so uh on the right hand side of this
graph you see that the capture select uh
the sea deck the histax these are the
smallest one yeah and they are also very
commonly used in in in in laboratory in
the laboratory so the advantage what you
see here is with this is an example for
the for the history so this is over
expression
of uh uh actually uh protein in uh E
coli
and then you have uh two different uh
type of chelates yeah so because the
heat stake itself yeah pain such uh to a
chelated nickel copper
Cobalt or or a thing and you we can
chelate this nickel copper copper or
sink with what is called nitrilic three
acetic acid or with Ida this is amino D
acetic acid and you see here we have a
lot of choices uh and uh you always see
uh on the left hand side of like for the
NDA is uh uh you have uh the the the the
supernatant yeah then the flow through
the wash and then they evaluate fraction
supinated Bosch Elio infection
and then you see uh with a lot of this
chelated uh uh metal ions in one step uh
a highly pure protein can be uh obtained
and we have a lot of choices of metal
ions and chelators yeah
in the lab we use quite often uh a
nickel yeah but a nickel is considered
as cartinogen and therefore for
industrial scale manufacturing this is
not so well assumed
so and then uh I I talked a lot about
the authentic and dominance and you will
question yourself why is he talking so
much about this
what is plotted here is the frequency of
the n-terminals uh in the human proteome
so you see this on the left hand side
yeah so 80 percent is alanine and ten
percent is searing and then you see that
and on the right hand side you see the
frequency of indominance in the human
serum protein yeah proteome yeah and
here you see glutamine alanine and so on
so so this is these are different ones
yeah
uh and what you see here the most of the
Techni mobiles are too unspecific to
expensive to produce this uh and this
authentic and Terminus yeah
uh and these Affinity takes to be
together with his history can vastly
simplify our purification
so so about have we done uh I already
mentioned cast spaces we have a
we have
used car space too and the caspase 2 has
the advantage
that it has a recognition side of five
amino acids yeah so and uh think about
when you have five amino acids the cell
activity will be very very uh will be
increased yeah and they are independent
of the B1 Prime side yeah so when you
use now a link with five amino acids are
actually linked to the B1 Prime side
yeah then they say it's ideal for the
generation of a native and Terminus for
Fusion proteins
don't we have what is called circular
permutated yeah uh because this then
allows a constitutive
expression yeah uh circular permutation
doesn't uh mean anything else that we
have
linked together uh uh pose uh uh chains
of this uh heterotimer so we have linked
the C terminals with uh with the n
terminals so that the protein is
expressed as a single chain
yeah
what you see here is this n-terminal
authentic CC and this audacity is uh
quite often
this is expressed the the cleavage is
k-cat over km yeah we measure this those
of you who are not familiar with enzyme
kinetics so this is a
is a a
parameter for the specificity
specificity but also for the cleavage
efficiency so and what you see here we
with with polar number of basic and
acidic proteins we have a different TV
traits
when we buy a process then we actually
are more interested in the time and here
you we have plotted the same thing yeah
but the time for 50 gibbage yeah so the
time to cleave off a fusion protein yeah
which an authentic and Terminus of with
glycine is less than one minute yeah and
then we need a couple of hours for uh uh
other acidic or for Brolin we need even
a day or more and it is uh not really
suitable
but uh uh what What's the advantages of
this uh enzyme is that it is uh I can
really highly overexpress you can highly
overexpress that to to a very high title
so a couple of grams per liter and
therefore uh an enzyme is available
for uh for it's an industrial purposes
so that you you can uh uh afford uh to
use such a strategy so
the further Advantage is that such an
enzyme and this is also really important
yeah is stable yeah uh at minus 20
degrees uh for two years so this can be
stored
and uh I think moreover this is more
important for laboratory scale rather
than industrial scale you would see you
see here on the right hand side it is
resistant to Freestyle yeah so it can to
be checked 25 times froze and some
thought it and almost no loss in
efficiency or in cleavage efficiency or
enzyme activity
so
how do we now proceed with such a a
generic platform for purification of
non-map proteins yeah
so we have the Affinity tag fusion
protein uh expression on the left hand
side yeah so the Affinity tag the red
ones are the impurities uh uh the green
is uh the Affinity text yeah then we do
an affinity chromatography in our case
it would be his stack yeah uh the the
deck protein Banks the the non-tech the
impurities they they flow through
and then uh uh actually the tech protein
will be uh eluded but it is also maybe a
little bit co-elluted uh with uh uh
other impurities
then we add the enzyme Cliff of the day
and do a subtractive Affinity
chromatography
the the the the the
cleaved uh protein will flow through the
Affinity chromatography and those
proteins who are actually not lived will
stick to this second Affinity
chromatography and we get a native
protein of interest uh pretty pure
so yeah I will show you an example uh uh
this is the case study for the
production of human fibroplasts growth
factor two fgf
so you can produce fgf by other other
means because it's a pretty acidic
alkaline protein but just as a model so
fgf2 was produced in E coli with this
n-terminal tag and this consisted of
this histax for for the Affinity a
Linker and then this caspase through
recognition sites so you see on the
right hand side the hiss tag the Linker
and then
the the the recognition side yeah for
actually the enzyme to make it more
specific so
here you see the advantage this is
expressed
in
a soluble protein with a relatively good
data so that uh actually you get about
uh two grams of protein per liter yeah
so that's uh that's a pretty uh uh a
good expression yeah so
uh now I will go through this slide to
show you uh the purification
of a platform yeah for the downstream
processing so the FD marker with the
left hand side the the SDS electroduces
the supernet and then we have the flow
through the wash yeah and then we elude
and after illusion you see uh uh uh the
cleavage
then after the cleavage you see the uh
actually differential or the subtractive
Affinity chromatography and uh you see
actually a pretty pure uh protein yeah
overall expression is great and a simple
a simple verification procedure a final
priority measured by a reverse phase
chromatography of 98 percent 40 PPM
wholesale protein which is spectacular
uh uh endotoxins and uh uh then you see
uh also uh rather low
um DNA uh uh contaminate impurities the
the major uh wholesale protein which has
co-iluted is uh DNA K and maybe have
interacted uh at which the
metal Chile Affinity chromatography yeah
uh I'm sure we could further reduce the
end of dog scenes yeah but we did not do
the endotoxin at the the second
subtractive Affinity chromatography with
endotoxin free monster and so on what
you would do in in case of Pharma
production
so here you see uh uh the upper slide
that you already saw how this fgf has
been constructed yeah uh and then uh the
panel C you see the the cleavage
kinetics
over time yeah and then we've seen uh
two hours we have a complete cleavage on
the right hand side you see uh Eclipse
cleavage kinetics and then also at the
k-cat yeah this is uh interested for
those who are uh actually interested in
in enzyme kinetics
so
now let's go to the next so the end
terminal authentic CC so is this fine
yeah but uh uh if we we are not
satisfied yeah uh here you see this
k-cat over km I already showed you yeah
so then what we did
we went to another a selection around so
we we selected yeah and you see here uh
this is the the
um
fgf the example is to do hours yeah for
for a lot of other proteins left of the
alanine uh could be processed much
faster but all those right uh uh there
is a lot of this uh uh uh in Germany
which would suffer from actually a long
lineage
top
we did then a further a screening I
don't go into this selection system you
see here our recent application profits
the bacterial selection system for the
directed evolution of uh proteases we
published this last year in general of
biological chemistry yeah
so we we could improve uh the enzyme
yeah we increased the P1 from its Equity
yeah increase the activity and have a
similar manufacturability and stabilize
as this original cast too so what you
see here then uh
the the the non-dashed uh bars see the
Improvement in kcat over km yeah and on
the very right hand side with the Brolin
you already see that this problem uh can
now be also cleaved pretty fast yeah but
again what I have uh uh
I want to show you because this cake has
over km is more for Science and if you
publish this but more meaningful is
again the uh time for 50 percent of
cleavage yeah so glycine was already one
minute so there was not a lot to improve
yeah but uh what we have you have seen
here uh
um that a lot of uh uh proteins now with
different uh and Dominus can be cleaved
uh we've seen less than one hour and
actually the Brolin Can Be when Brolin
is to enter the authentic and Dominus
can be lived also in a couple of hours
and now uh the system is really ready to
uh be used for a lot of different uh uh
uh uh proteins so
so here you see uh uh here you see the
the system uh then we overexpressed also
thermonacrosis Factor this Valley yeah
so this was the original you see then on
the left hand side yeah uh the error the
arrow points to uh uh actually uh the
gleavage over time the blue one is the
original case space two circular
permeated and then the other one is uh
ones are the cleavage uh kinetics
of the improved cash space
yeah so you see uh that we could
substantially improve this at everything
what is below one hour is uh uh actually
completely suited for uh for industry
so uh I will Globe a pretty soon come to
an end so accessible examples what we
have done so far where fibroblasts goes
back to two domonecrosis Factor Alpha
direct hormone human growth hormone
granola sites Colony stimulating Factor
super excise this motives and nowadays
everybody is working also on sarskov too
so we do the sarskov to nuclear protein
and that with our collaboration partner
parenting England we also over expressed
successfully eight additional in-house
proteins but there is a drug candidates
and they don't want to disclose the
nature of these uh proteins yeah
and here you see we have recently
published this also uh last year the
overexpression of the South Cove to
nuclear protein and this is already used
in a diagnostic kit for such cove2
antipolis
last part of my uh talk actually for the
for the card space too I wanna actually
have to I want to acknowledge the team
yeah so the Institute of Tire processing
science and engineering The Institute
for molecular modeling and simulation
The Institute of biochemistry from the
University of Innsbruck and paranga
ingelheim the bioprocess Pharma
bioprocess science Austria so you see
this is a huge team
necessary uh to accomplish such a task
I hope uh I could give you an overview
on the manufacturing of proteins what
are the challenges yeah and then our uh
uh uh in-house example which actually
has successfully now transferred to
Industry because uh this uh approach
this technology is now used for uh
manufacturing of clinical phase material
not yet for full-scale manufacturing
finally part of this work has been
financed by the Austrian Center of
industrial biotechnology which is a a
company
owned by the Technical University of
grads my University the University of
Innsbruck and the the the
the University of grads yeah
so uh now I think I have at the end of
this my presentation and I would be glad
to to actually answer questions or or to
get your feedback or or comments to my
presentation
thank you so much Dr Young Berger for
that informative presentation and we
will now start the live q a portion of
this webinar if you have any questions
you want to ask please do so now just
use that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen
so let's get started
Dr Young Burger we have some great
questions already coming in from our
audience
our first question
when do you want to express a protein as
an inclusion body
uh inclusion bodies are not very uh
very well accepted in in industry but
also not in Academia
but sometimes you have a protein which
is toxic to the cell
so it's toxic so it would actually
reduce uh the growth of the cell or it
would uh even kill the cell and then
it's almost impossible to overexpress it
in such cases inclusion bodies are a way
out uh to to get the recombinant
proteins in large
amounts that that's really why we are
interested of why people are interested
still in inclusion bodies
other
reason why you wanna overexpress in
inclusion bodies it's the high
expression type
sometimes you would get up to 30 grams
of protein per liter
thank you so much and talking about
overexpression have you ever over
expressed viral proteins yeah you see we
have overexpressed the viral proteins to
nuclear protein but we have also over
expressed uh now
proteins from C Cabarrus yeah we have
not yet a fully purified them and
characterized them yeah so we have we
have done this yeah
thank you so much and I want to thank
our audience for their questions today
is there a rule for C negative or an
native terminal tagging of fusion
proteins Dr Amber
uh
quite often uh proteins are decked and
via the end Terminus yeah
so this is the most common one yeah
often the end Terminus may be
hidden in the inside of the protein yeah
and therefore a protease cannot leave
off uh diffusion take
so in such a case you would go for a c
terminal
Fusion yeah but it's also sometimes a
matter of what you have established in
your life
thank you so much we have time for a
couple more questions is the fusion
protein technology scalable
uh
what I uh have seen so far yes it is it
is scalable uh uh until uh uh recently
uh the fusion protein technology uh
suffered from the high price of the
enzymes for Cleavage if you want to go
to a real large-scale operation
thank you very much and we have time for
one more question is it always necessary
to generate a Target protein with
authentic and terminus
no it's not it's not yeah uh especially
especially when we actually want to use
a protein yeah for
um uh as as a vaccine yeah
uh then it is necessary because we could
get an apparent immune response with the
protein yeah where the uh n-dominus is
not at our authentic uh there are a
couple of proteins they need the full
activity uh uh for full activity the
authentic endurance will be required
yeah
but sometimes it is not necessary
Dr Young Berger I want to thank you for
your presentation today do you have any
final comments you'd like to make to our
audience before we go
oh about this would be the final
comments uh uh uh Don't Be Afraid uh uh
um if you have to purify a protein which
is a non-antibody there are many ways
actually to accomplish this task
well I want to thank you again Dr Young
Bauer for your time today and for your
important research and before we go I
want to thank our audience for joining
us as well and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for two years until April 6
2024. lab Roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone bye-bye
okay